okay today I'm going to talk to you
about microwaves we're going to have a
look at microwaves in context of the
rest of the electromagnetic spectrum and
we're going to have a look at the main
two uses of microwaves as well so first
of all here is the electromagnetic
spectrum
as you can see microwaves sit between
radio waves and infrared it means they
have a lower frequency than all of these
types of wave but they have a higher
frequency than radio waves just like the
rest of the waves in the electromagnetic
spectrum
they are transverse waves that travel at
300 million meters per second through a
vacuum so let's have a look at the main
two uses of microwaves now the first one
is communication so you may not know
that actually your mobile phones use
microwaves to transfer information so
your mobile phones send microwaves to
mobile telephone masts which then sends
information to other phones they can
also be used in order to have
communication to and from satellites so
let's imagine here's is a little diagram
of the earth now above the earth we have
the layer of gases called the atmosphere
now the reason why microwaves can be
used to transfer information to
satellites so here's a satellite which
is orbiting the Earth and it's above the
Earth's atmosphere so the reason why it
could be used is microwaves or certain
types of microwave can travel through
the Earth's atmosphere without being
absorbed by the Earth's atmosphere so
this particular thing here this
satellite what it can do is it can
basically receive the signal from from a
microwave sent from Earth and it can
then send basically transmitted another
microwave to another part of the earth
so microwaves can be used in terms of
communication this microwave can then be
picked up by receiver on the surface of
the earth so that's one part of
microwaves how they can be used for
communication the other use that I think
most of us will already be aware of is
microwave ovens oops sorry
microwave ovens so essentially
microwaves can be used to heat up food
so let's imagine we've got this this
food here that we want to heat up so
here is inside the microwave oven so
what happens is within the microwave
oven
we we we fire microwaves at the food and
the way that it works is this these
microwaves are absorbed by water
molecules now this is a bit weird isn't
it because the reason why these
microwave works for keep communication
was the fact that they weren't absorbed
by water molecules so if we have a quick
think about the electromagnetic spectrum
we can see that some microwaves so let's
say for example the ones on this side
near-infrared have a higher frequency
and some microwaves have a lower
frequency there's a range of different
microwaves within this classification
here so that's the reason why some of
them are absorbed by water molecules and
some are not absorbed by water molecules
so as they absorb as these water
molecules absorb they absorb the
microwaves they gain more thermal energy
so they have more and more thermal
energy so these water molecules can then
transfer the energy so transfer the
energy to the rest of the molecules in
the food so this is why extremely
extremely dry dried foods could not
really be effectively heated in a
microwave if there's no water molecules
in there in the first place it's
difficult to
to heat it up because it's the water
molecules vibrate in and and gain in
more energy into their thermal store
that then transfers the energy
throughout the rest of the food so that
is basically all we need to know at this
stage about microwaves thank you